لم يكن هذا التوتر هو الاول من نوعه بشان
تايوان فمنذ انفصال الصين وتايوان في
نهايه الحرب الاهليه الصينيه عام
1949 اصبح المضيق الذي يفصل بينهما نقطه
توتر جاسوسيه ويتحدث المؤرخون عن ثلاث
ازمات سابقه اندلعت الازمه الاولى في اب
اغسطس عام
1954 حين ارسل التايوان الاف الجنود الى
جزيره
الخاضعتين لحكمها واردت الصين بقصف مدفعي
للجزيرتين واستولت على جزر بيجيا نقشان
اندلع القتال مجددا في عام
1958 عندما قصفت القوات الصينيه
جزيرتينمين وماتسو في مسعا لطرد القوات
التايوانيه
وخشى ان تؤدي خساره الجزيره الى انهيار
القوميين في تايوان وسيطره
امر الرئيس الامريكي
قواته بدعم حلفائه التايوانيين اشتعل
التوتر مجددا عام
1995 عندما بدات الصين تجارب اطلاق صواريخ
في المياه المحيطه بتايوان وذلك احتجاجا
على زياره رئيس تايوان
لامريكا في ذلك الوقت بعد عامين اي في عام
1997 زار رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
تايوان في خطوه غير مسبوقه وتبعته رئيسه
المجلس نانسي بيلوسي بعد 25 عاما ثم توالت
بعد ذلك لقاءات المسؤولين التايوانيين
بمشرعين امريكيين لترد الصين باطلاق اكبر
مناورات جويه وبحريه